Okay, so I bet you know what I'm going to ask you now.
I'm going to ask you to code it up yourself.
If you guessed that, you'd be correct.
so, let me show you what I did,
and then you're going to be able to make a SVM, just like I did.
So, what I would suggest, is you head back to Google, just like I did,
find this page on the Support Vector Machines' documentation from scikit-learn.
Remember, that if you scroll down just a little bit,
you'll find this Classification section.
And, down here, is the example code that I used to get my code running.
Now, there's one little hiccup, one little catch.
In exactly how we created the classifier, right here.
So, what I'm going to do is actually get you started with this
line and this line.
And, you'll see that there's a little difference in the way
that I wrote my code.
We're going to be talking about this a lot in the next few videos.
But now it's your job to fit, and make predictions using your classifier.
And then, the last thing that I want you to do is to print out the accuracy of
your classifier, the way that we did in Naive Bayes.
remember, Naive Bayes the number to beat was about 88.4%.
So, there's, there's an interesting question.
Is an SVM, or
Naive Bayes doing a better job of classifying your terrain in this example?